well just I've completed my basic law
studies from the Faculty of law of Delhi
University and then I I was working at
the National Human Rights Commission in
India for a year after which I got the
route scholarship to go to Oxford I did
my masters in law at the University
College Oxford
after which I got admission to the
Harvard Law School where I completed my
LLM and I briefly worked at a New York
law firm for a year after which I
decided to move into academia I was a
visiting fellow at NYU Law School after
that and then I did some teaching and
research in Japan after which around in
from middle of 2002 onwards I have been
honking for the last over five years and
that was that's my essentially in my
academic background